[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il faut faire la solution d'un
côté oui c'est ça alors tout fait la
solution à côté d'autres par ici les
opérations et numérotées oui comment
faut-il pas faire par exemple plus
attention à ton cahier où tu as une
feuille parce que jour des certificats
évidemment on a des feuilles on a des
feuilles tour pour faire ses solutions
pour faire ses opérations qu'elles font
ils pas fait faut il ne faut pas faire
la solution
oui de quelle raison parce qu'un discret
de se taire
la dictée c'était la loi du travail et
je vous rappelle que j'avais fait une
faute c'est à la fin c'était fais ce que
dois advienne que pourra et j'avais mis
or
et enfin mon gars
[Musique]
ne rien oublier j'espère
et papac de thouars
une et le vichyssois remet l'ustr 64
1864 oui ça fait cent trois ans à
l'époque avait pas de certificat
d'études ah non il ya le coût reste coi
grosse différence
en fait
oprah je me rappelle cette appli qualité
c'était quelque chose on montre des lois
celui qu'il avait mais ce qui était le
plus beau c'est quand on disait
or là il a son brevet élémentaire
hors ca c'etait un c'était un surhomme
par bougel par bonjour et le bassiste
jean michel c'est là il se rebelle
voilà bien travaillé
[Musique]